I love following him on Twitter at Josh
GAD and what he does and the the
happiness he brings to people is
immeasurable
if only is Miami Dolphins could return
Josh GAD here on the Rich Eisen show how
are you Josh lovely introduction
my fish no hold on a second now well two
is here to us yeah now are you are you
are you all in on to like you know I'm
all in on Brian Flores like me too there
isn't anything that approach I think
with this organization I and I say that
as somebody who literally had the
Dolphins winning maybe one game last
season and was as like awestruck and
stunned as everybody outside of Miami by
what they managed to string together
included nothing singing win against the
bad well I mean I got to tell you Josh
you you want to put it all together tank
for two of I mean I was hearing about
tanking for two of for the Miami
Dolphins literally when he beat Georgia
in the national champ ship game and then
when it was now time to actually put
this into plan this plan into place
and it was time to start tanking for tua
with brine flores is their new head
coach and then Ryan Fitzpatrick is their
quarterback there was no tanking going
on those that that's the anti-tank
quarterback in the history of anti-tank
quarterbacks and Ryan somehow you know
we get to I think without treating
anything in return it's just such a
shock
dolphin fans were kind of like we didn't
know what to do with no final record
because losing that first pick and
losing the opportunity or so we thought
to get to or without the first three
picks was something that I think we were
just all like God and yet here we are
and I thought the Dolphins just in
general had a great draft I think
they're really smart if they're making
all the right moves it's not a gun you
can go back and listen to previous
previous interviews you and I have done
together and I probably said the same
thing about like Tony Sparano at some
point so you are you are Josh GAD you
are all about the positive you're as I
said you're a delight you like
delighting people you like being happy
you like being having love in the world
I know this about you I've seen this
about you and yet and yet though the
desire to be so absolutely overjoyed out
of the spite of beating New England at
the end of a season that was otherwise
totally lost for you to be motivated by
that particular piece of spite I think
is is is exactly what fandom is all
about but that one didn't cost them
eventually you know a week off when the
poor turn offs I mean yes kind of yeah
yeah put it all in a motion in that last
loss that the dolphin stuck it to New
England to get them out of a bi-week
spot to put them in Foxborough the first
week to be one and done to buy the
Titans and Vrabel that is a particular
chef's kiss type of stuff right there
for a dolphin film a to be a exceedance
for over a decade and hasn't just been a
domination it's been
depressing noodle existence for a fan
ever liked Jets build and dolphins fans
just had to live with Superman in their
division for so long that it was only
fair to finally overthrow this boots on
of the other dynasty yes and then you
take a look at it and then just to I
guess put it a full circle little button
on it the Miami Dolphins are in New
England to open the season in 2020 so
maybe two of those or fits magic you
know works is magic again and starts
things off that would be amazing
yet for you I would love to it you know
to really get help I hope they don't put
them out there and destroy and before he
has a chance to really come into his own
because it's an unforgiving game and I
want the bad I have every opportunity to
honestly become the next marionette to
become the great superstar and City have
been longing for for my entire lifetime
Josh GAD here on the Rich Eisen show so
much going on with your career I'd love
to hit them all with you
Artemis Fowl Disney Fantasy and adultery
and adventure film available for
streaming this Friday Disney Plus what a
cast you Judi Dench Colin Farrell
Kenneth Branagh directs it what can
people expect from this one Josh Homme
I'm so excited was originally supposed
to be theatrical and obviously given the
state of affairs right now that be
ongoing pandemic I think there's made a
really bold and exciting choice to
premiered and there's new person it
gives everybody a chance to see a really
cool adventure film laced with magic
based on a series of beloved books by
author and culture and the movie is
tremendous it's actually I'm gonna last
one I saw on the big screen before I had
to show up in the place it's a screening
of it on the bidding a lot and
and I could nothing less well I think
people are going to get definitely gonna
get their money's worth good at best how
do you out is one prepare to play a
filthy kleptomaniac dwarf as you've been
described for your character watching
the Rangers there's a little bit you
know I like to think of mulch as hazard
by way of some so this guy is a loner
he's sort of out for himself you can't
quite tell what side if anyone and and
and there's a lot of that sort of like
Han Solo roguishness him definitely
nothing look I'm definitely clearly
sexier than such a great character such
a great film and I can't wait for
everything to see its products again
Friday June 12th is when you could start
streaming it on Disney Plus and then
you've mentioned Lord of the Rings Josh
GAD what you are doing on your YouTube
stream by getting some of the most
iconic films and television and back
together and the cast's back together is
amazing I can't imagine how you have
been able to pull all of this off I
assume you're getting help to get all
these folks together I mean Lord of the
Rings Goonies Back to the Future splash
you know hey Ron Howard are you free
when Tom Hanks is free I mean like is
that is that what you're doing to get
everybody back together a lot of people
that I greatly admire all in the name of
charity you know the truth is is that
people clearly have more time on their
hands than usual right now and and then
you know a zoo call if it's an
opportunity to raise money for for
charities like the Center for disaster
philanthropy or a wife and make an ugly
which we breathe as of today over a
hundred and thirty thousand dollars
I think people people are really into
that idea and and I'm glad that it's
providing so many with so much joy at a
time when I've been people really it's
truly amazing and is it true you're next
you're next you're next shot is the
Ghostbusters reunion so what you're
doing is we're editing that Batman and I
could not be more excited for the
surprises in store and and it's going to
be it's going to be hopefully an elixir
to these uh these interesting dark times
that we find ourselves in and and give
people not only a you know an
opportunity to laugh and go revisit one
of my all-time favorite poems but but
also raise some money for some
incredibly appropriate calls
all right so let's see bookie Bill
Murray is just like you want to talk
about a white whale I mean isn't it like
you got to call a number it's like a pay
phone somewhere and somebody nested
right and then they pass a long message
to Bill and Bill's like yeah I'll do it
is that is that is that true for
anything that is all true that is
absolutely true and how do you fit they
Stay Puft Marshmallow Man into a zoom
square great question Josh you know
fingers is very hard clicking every
button on the pad so I mean like cuz you
could also go Rick Moranis here's
Sigourney Weaver I mean this I'm locked
in if you know on all of these it's
amazing yet the whole Goonies cast can I
make us it can I can I make a suggestion
we've we've got some some relaxed
I would love to get a reunion
of midnight run even though I know I
know a couple a couple of the octaves of
percents past but Yaphet Kotto is 80
okay you know do do Grodin and DeNiro
and I would just love to just get the
whole I don't know how it's not a like a
nun SOT like Joey pants right you got
him great I haven't thought of it and
Midnight Runners approachable home I
think I think the really nice part is is
both great an engineer is very
approachable so I Josh everyone
obviously wants to do it for you it
really is something I know it's I just
love that movie I don't know I would
love to know some back stories you know
to just see what happens I wanted to do
varsity blues know you want to do
Shawshank something off the record which
means that only you and everyone who
listens to this show cannot yes I had
started reaching out to the palace of
Shawshank Redemption if there would be
any possibility of bringing them
together it is in my opinion one of the
greatest movies of the last century but
you know it's it's these things are
really it's all about the participants
and whether or nothing in a revisit
peaceful so I have done the reach out
and hopefully they say yes because I
tend to agree Shawshank being said and
again people just go and put reunited
apart into YouTube and then that's how
they can find everything correct yeah
you can go to youtube / Josh GAD to make
easy and grand all because it's it's
great the episodes are really great and
doing it for a good cause
alright and then Central Park as the
animated musical sitcom that premiered a
couple of Fridays ago about a family
that lives in Central Park that looks to
be honest with you I'm looking at the
the cast it looks like half Hamilton
half frozen with
I'm Junior daveed Diggs you and Kristen
Bell just a name for so what it looks
like to me yeah and and and then we
obviously at the sentence of people like
Stanley Tucci well it is such a
tremendous test and and such a
tremendous show I'm so blessed to call
myself a co-creator on it along with
their and besides we created Bob's
Burgers and no it's not also Bob's
Burgers is there's just something so
joyful about this series and everyone
who's been watching it has been you know
paying that forward to too often and
letting us know how much not only the
show itself but incredible music written
by an assortment of geniuses including
Kate Anderson and the Lisa pencil and
Breton often and some unbelievable best
composers like Cindy Walker Aimee Mann
Wow so it's a great group and and and
the show is currently on Apple Plus and
it is a must watch yeah and today I'm
Aimee Mann the Magnolia soundtrack is
one of the greatest movie soundtracks of
all time I think that like everybody you
know kids again when I saw the cast here
in half frozen half Hamilton I just
thought what if they mixed right that a
revolution was brought to arendelle or
when the British were or that when the
British were were fighting against the
Colonials if they just got frozen
literally like just like well Josh
before I let you go you have been here
before and it's always a delight when
you are here my sound man I sound
engineer my audio executives he likes to
be called Mike del to fo 54 year old
single man or divorced man from the
state of New Jersey
now here's the thing it's like what's
the what's the oldest Olaf man you've
ever come across know like like like
have all the stuffed animals have all
the oh yeah you surprised a lot connects
Milton generationally I mean there are
there are people who are in their 80s
and 90s who like Familia who let me know
how important that character is I think
the reason that saying people connect
for that little diet versa there is a
sense of like child childlike wonderment
that I think a lot of us forget that we
have even when we're older and it
reminds us of the purity of looking at
the word optimism Mike you do want to
say something I am I mean because here's
a great character you started how many
Olaf items do you have in your house
what's the gloves a full-size one okay
then every I have like the full-size one
and then I have moldable in the cup
holder in the rear of my one car that's
not weird at all I'm gonna put you on
the spot before I go can you how it Olaf
term the drafting of two Otunga of Aloha
to the Dolphins can you can you can you
tell me what to have thought about that
draft or the or beating the doll of
beating the Patriots and knocking them
out of the the by weak position do you
got something for me on that front
Josh got the New England pages
you're the best keep doing what you're
doing
[Music]
take care yourself Jess that is Josh GAD
at josh gana both Twitter and Instagram
Artemis Fowl this Friday June 12th on
Disney Plus Central Park on Apple TV
plus has been available since the final
Friday in May and then go again to
youtube.com slash Josh GAD I'm telling
you these reunions are amazing I do not
know I mean the thing that's so
impressive the logistics it must take to
get everybody to zoom in it at the same
time hey you watched all the way to the
end thanks for that watch more right
here